well so nice to see you great to see you
my man
you look you look fantastic as you
always do I have to ask you I'm a little
confused okay about your face there's
face paint your worried face painting I
know what the significance is I don't
know what's happening right now I I was
at a kid's birthday party and I didn't
have time to wipe it off my face cuz I
was running late I know how you guys
like to start on time yeah yeah for
groanin show yeah
look out yeah I'm driving home and I see
this house with a bunch of party
balloons and you know bouncy house in
the back and I'm like that looks like a
kid's birthday party
yeah walked in turns out I know his old
is old lady oh you know his mom his mom
yeah when I used to hang out for a while
so I thought what's going on here yeah
and she says Justin's birthday yeah I'm
like can I stay next thing you know I'm
getting my face painted like a tiger
yeah I think that's a great I think
that's a very sweet story you went to a
birthday party you got your face painted
let's we I think we had a great time
really fun I hated to leave yeah but
it's great to be here thank you and
thank you yeah well yeah I'm just gonna
move on with the interview and we're
just gonna forget that this is happening
up here but yeah you would be foolish to
do anything else yes of course yeah look
I I just feel really bad that I had to
leave Justin's birthday party and you
know whenever I go to kids birthday
parties I always sing a song
if you knew yeah whether they want to
hear it or not today how often do they
want to hear it lessons less than zero
but I promise Justin I I knew he's gonna
be watching tonight that I would sing
him a song he's a huge carpenter's fan
Justin how old is this kid he's eight
years old he's eight and he loves the
karpin's very sophisticated tastes all
right specifically the song superstar so
if you'll indulge me I'd like to sing
superstar by Karen Carpenter
the Justin
thank you everyone
you know what Conan also want to add a
caveat to this I'm going to sing the
entire song from beginning the end so do
not interrupt me if you interrupt me I
will start again from the beginning this
is for you Justin hand oh so far away I
fell in love with you before the second
show I'm not done your guitar it sounds
so sweet and clear but you're not really
here it's just the radio the entire song
don't you remember I told me love me
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
I really do you know what Justin was a
really fun birthday party but I'm
actually really good friends with your
mom Virginia and I don't want to say
that I'm your dad
but I'm your dad that's not that's not
how a kid should find out who his father
is that's that's insane that's not the
way to do it that's completely wrong
in a signal so we don't have time and I
can hardly wait to be with you again
[Music]
[Applause]
you mean the houses in tears Danny stop
[Music]
I just
I am a next guests are from West Plains
Missouri where were the signs on their
new album heart shape Mountain you
become on July 20th should be appearing
at Winsley in Nashville Tennessee
searches
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to thank my guests tonight of
course well for being here
[Applause]
[Music]
but for being on the show you got
[Applause]
[Music]
you